>>> THE FBI
IS JOINING THE INVESTIGATION
INTO POWER OUTAGES IN NORTH
CAROLINA THAT OFFICIALS SAY WERE
CAUSED BY INTENTIONAL AND
TARGETED ATTACKS.
MORE THAN 35,000 CUSTOMERS ARE
WAKING UP WITHOUT POWER AFTER
GUN FIRE LEFT DAMAGE.
>> THE PERPETRATOR, IT WILL BE
BROUGHT TO JUSTICE AND
PROSECUTED TO THE FULLEST EXTENT
OF THE LAW.
>> A MANDATORY OVERNIGHT WAS
LIFTED IN THE LAST HOUR.
WHITNEY WILD IS IN NORTH
CAROLINA.
AND SHE FILED THIS REPORT.
>> THERE IS A LOT MORE WE DON'T
KNOW THAN WE DO KNOW.
LAW ENFORCEMENT HERE SAYING THE
FBI IS INVOLVED AS WELL AS THE
STATE BUREAU OF INVESTIGATION.
RIGHT NOW ALL THEY CAN SAY IS
THESE TWO SUBSTATIONS SUSTAINED
GUN FIRE AND ONE OF THE GATES
LEADING INTO THE SUBSTATIONS
APPEARS TO HAVE BEEN TAKEN OFF
THE HINGES.
AS FAR AS THE MOTIVE, LAW
ENFORCEMENT CAN'T SAY WHAT THE
REASON IS.
THERE HAD BEEN SOME TALK ON
SOCIAL MEDIA THAT THIS MAY HAVE
BEEN CONNECTED TO A DRAG SHOW
SOMEWHERE IN MOORE COUNTY.
HOWEVER, LAW ENFORCEMENT CAN'T
SAY THAT'S THE MOTIVE RIGHT NOW
UNTIL THEY'RE ABLE TO FIGURE OUT
WHO DID THIS AND THEY SAY THEY
HAVE NO IDEA WHO DID THIS, THE
MOTIVE IS GOING TO BE EXTREMELY
DIFFICULT TO FIGURE OUT.
MEANWHILE, HERE IN MOORE COUNTY,
SCHOOLS ARE CLOSED UNTIL AT
LEAST TOMORROW.
AGAIN, MORE THAN 40,000 PEOPLE
ARE WITHOUT POWER.
THE LIKELIHOOD HERE IS THAT
POWER WON'T BE RESTORED UNTIL
THURSDAY.
I FOUND THIS BIZARRE AND
TROUBLING.
WE CAN GET INTO THE QUESTIONS
ABOUT POTENTIAL DOMESTIC
TERRORISM.
WHAT IS YOUR ASSESSMENT THIS
MORNING?
>> FIRST OF ALL, WE'VE SEEN THIS
BEFORE.
THE FIRST TIME THIS CAME UP WAS
2013 IN THE MED CALF CAMP IN
CALIFORNIA.
HUNDREDS OF ROUNDS OF SNIPER
POSITIONS TOOK OUT 17
TRANSFORMERS DID $15 MILLION
WORTH OF DAMAGE.
BUT IN THAT ONE THEY WERE ABLE
TO REROUTE POWER TO OTHER
STATIONS, NOT GO THROUGH A BIG
BLACKOUT.
BUT IT TOOK WEEKS TO REPAIR.
AND BECAUSE OF THAT INCIDENT, WE
IN THE NEW YORK CITY POLICE
DEPARTMENT, OUR PARTNERS AT CON
ED, CONGRESS, THE DEPARTMENT OF
ENERGY, STARTED LOOKING AT WHAT
IS THE SECURITY ON THE
ELECTRICAL GRID?
MADE A LOT OF CHANGES AND
RECOMMENDATIONS, THIS IS THE
SECOND ONE OF THESE WE'VE SEEN.
THE REAL QUESTION IS MOTIVE, WAS
IT TO TAKE OUT THE POWER
STATION, WAS IT TO DENY POWER TO
A THEATRE THAT WAS HOLDING A
CONTROVERSIAL LGBTQ EVENT THAT
NIGHT IN MOORE COUNTY WHERE THE
THEATRE WAS BLACKED OUT AND THEY
HAD TO CALL OFF THE SHOW.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT RIGHT NOW.
>> THAT WAS MY QUESTION IS WHY.
BECAUSE THE LOCAL SHERIFF
DEFERRED THOSE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT, WHETHER IT
WAS A DOMESTIC TERRORISM ATTACK
SAYING WE HAVE TO FIGURE THIS
OUT.
SO WHERE IS THIS INVESTIGATION
RIGHT NOW AND HOW DO YOU FIGURE
THAT OUT?
>> THE FIRST THING YOU'RE
LOOKING FOR IS A COMMUNICATION,
IF IT HAS A POLITICAL PURPOSE,
USUALLY THE PERSON BEHIND IT
WANTS TO ANNOUNCE THAT AND SAY
IT WAS US AND IT WAS FOR X.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT YET.
>> FOR THE PURPOSE OF WHAT?
WHY WOULD SOMEONE DO THIS JUST
FOR CHAOS?
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
>> WELL, IT'S REALLY INTERESTING
ABOUT THE TIMING.
ON NOVEMBER 30th, DHS SENT OUT A
CONFIDENTIAL ADVISORY TO LAW
ENFORCEMENT SO THAT'S JUST A FEW
DAYS AGO, SAYING WE ARE IN A
HEIGHTENED THREAT PERIOD FOR
DOMESTIC VIOLENT EXTREMISTS, A.
B, TARGETS WILL LIKELY INCLUDE
LGBTQ EVENTS AND TARGETS
CRITICAL INFRASTRUCTURE,
GOVERNMENT TARGETS.
SO THIS IS ALREADY OUT THERE IN
THE ETHER.